le monastère notre dame de l'atlas est
le dernier site chrétiens d'algérie où
l'on n'ait entendu sonner les cloches
car aujourd'hui les églises font silence
c'est ici que les sept moines trappistes
ont été enlevés à une heure du matin
les groupes islamistes armés sont très
actifs dans cette région de montagne une
centaine d'entre eux auraient été tués
dans des accrochages ces trois derniers
jours précisément dans cette région de
médéa où a eu lieu l'enlèvement
parmi les sept trappistes enlevés se
trouve le père supérieur christian de
chergé mais les hommes voulaient surtout
enlever le frère médecin afin qu'ils
soignent un de leurs blessés tous et le
religieux savaient le danger qu'il
courait il ya eu cet arbre 93 le
massacre des croates 13 croate qui était
tout juste à côté d'eux c'était des
croates chrétiens qui allait au
monastère donc question s'est posée ce
moment là depuis ce temps là il ya eu
onze religieux les gestes ont été tués
normalement de l'ordre dans les lieux où
ils travaillaient normalement
à chaque fois la question s'est posée
alors il s'agit de savoir est ce que on
continue notre présence de témoignages
ou des seins si on fait le jeu des
des violents dans la nuit de noël il ya
deux ans le grain groupe était venu pour
permette avenue durant la nuit ça va
réunit tous les frères et il avait exigé
des frères une collaboration
collaboration au point de vue du médecin
qui devra aller dans la montagne point
de vue argent et quel point fait aussi
et les frères ont refusé et ont dit non
nous ne pouvons pas depuis 93 11
religieux dont sept français ont été
tués dans des attentats
mais ces hommes et ces femmes de foi ont
tous décidé de continuer d'aider la
population algérienne
près de 300 religieux étrangers vivrait
encore en algérie mais régulièrement ils
enterrent l'un des leurs
l'enlèvement des sept religieux français
montre les limites de l'action du
nouveau gouvernement qui avait promis
que la paix civile reviendrai après
l'élection présidentielle
[Musique]